The Joe Rogan Experience it reminds me
of I don't want to this is the only way
I can [ __ ] on this because I think he's
great when you look at the Rock's
Instagram I have to say this publicly
because I respect this person so much
his cheat Day meals really bother me
they're insane they're insane but
they're not indulgent I'm sorry it'll be
like boy has like giant pancakes and
cookies they don't look like regular
pancakes it's never like buttermilk
whipped cream it's like protein coconut
pineapple with like flavonoid peanut
butter and then taramana tequila like
it's never like the full Indulgence and
turkey bacon that's an Indulgence he has
turkey bacon lots of it I'm just like
let loose like where's that block of
cheese and like an IV of chili well
he'll have like a giant tray of sushi
but it's garbage Dwayne you have
millions of dollars like it's Costco
Sushi really it just doesn't look it's
like a rainbow roll and like like you
can afford the best sushi that's what he
likes no no he doesn't like it it's
something something's up there you think
I this I just I want as a wish
fulfillment when I look at that I want
to see Full Indulgence not like
protein-powered plant-based peanut
butter I don't think that's what he does
go to go to his Instagram finally
waiting with this most recently it's in
a video so he's getting to he's talking
but what does he got there he does have
turkey bacon okay like is this fun for
you it's [ __ ] here's a whole family
of chickens okay free corn muffin that's
what I'm saying this is no fun yeah
turkey bacon is definitely not fun I
don't understand but you know I mean
that's a guy that literally makes his
living off of being lean I hear that but
I'm saying if you go to the top I know
this one recently because it's something
that I bond with my old assistant over
is looking at his cheat meals I think
it's all the way at the top or you know
I don't know where it is now it's these
pancakes that just don't look right
between The Rock Johnson I'm calling you
out
they got like peanut butter and it's
like coconut coconut to me is one of
those like sugar substitute kind of
things that's all we got here look at
this that looks good coconut banana
pancake smothered with peanut butter
blessed with maple syrup that's [ __ ]
pretty indulgent I don't know something
about it because the peanut butter you
could like that's my protein something
about it I don't know he likes peanut
butter maybe it's just in your head
maybe you need to let it go you trying
to Gaslight me what is your I'm trying
to food chain this man you're trying to
guess like me I don't think it's food
chain doesn't make any sense to me I'm
just trying to like I'm trying to see
your perspective but it doesn't I'm not
seeing the full caloric blast I'm seeing
I'm just I'm wanting to see oh it's
pretty [ __ ] caloric full back of
bacon I'm wanting to see heavy whipped
cream eat all that maple syrup fruit
compote you don't know you don't see
that bottle you don't know what that is
that could be Elmer's glue and he
doesn't think it's like some sugar-free
maple syrup is that what you're thinking
I think those are keto pancakes
sugar-free Agave tinted nectar
and creatine powder mixed in with nuts I
don't think so looks like regular
pancakes no way too chunky something's
going on yeah something's going on Joe I
don't know looks normal to me okay
I'm a pancake well thanks for having me
I like
well there you go in and Out Burgers
Fries double doubles for the tequila
that looks good it's a different meal
yeah yeah that's solid right